hello you are really lucky why because
you're about to learn how to play chess
chess is a really really old game almost
2,000 years old
chess is a game where two players play
against each other on a chess board made
up of 64 squares an 8x8 grid each player
gets a bunch of different pieces that
they use to try and go after the other
players King what is it called when you
get the other side's King checkmate
you're right today I'm going to teach
you about the different pieces how they
move and how to checkmate each of the
six different kinds of pieces has its
own shape for moving most pieces cannot
move through other pieces only the
knight can jump over anyone that gets in
his way
also note piece can ever share a square
with another piece that square isn't big
enough for the two of us sorry
however they can be moved to take the
place of an opponent's piece that's how
you capture the enemies now let's go
meet our team the King is the most
important piece since losing him means
the end of the game but he is also one
of the weakest so very often he needs
his friends to protect him the King can
move one square in any direction up down
to the sides and diagonally see this
would be one move now after my
opponent's move I can go again for
example here how many moves will it take
me to get to the edge of the board three
that's right the King may never move
himself unto a square where it could be
captured it's not losing on purpose
if your opponent ever moves their King
onto a square where you can take it
don't grab the king and laughs I win
instead you should explain why they
can't move there then your opponent can
put the King back where it was and
choose a different move let's test you
and the white king move here no good how
about here
yes very good and here nope I think you
got it so let's keep going
when another piece threatens to capture
the king it's called check when there is
no way for the King to escape check it
is called checkmate as stated before and
that is how you win there are only three
ways a king can get out of check move
out of the way block the check with
another piece or capture the piece
that's checking you at the end of this
video when you know the other pieces
will show some examples of this if a
king cannot escape checkmate then the
game is over customarily the king is not
captured or removed from the board the
game is simply over the queen is the
most powerful piece like the king she
can move in any one straight direction
forward backward sideways or diagonally
but unlike the king the queen is very
speedy in fact she can move as far as
you like as long as she does not move
through any other pieces hold on and
like with all other pieces if the Queen
captures an opponent's piece that's the
square she stops on all right 30 seconds
super intense practice can the Queen
move here no way she doesn't have a
teleporter to go anywhere she has to
follow a straight line okay how about
here yes good can she capture this piece
you bet
how about this one yeah him too and this
one Wow
the Queen is pretty strong right
alright let's test how fast she is can
she get to the top of the board in one
move yes and what square would she land
on that one how many moves would it take
her to go to the left side two tests
complete she's very fast the rook is
also sometimes called the castle some of
my friends like to call it a tower of
power that's because usually rooks look
like towers or castles and they're
pretty strong to the rook moves much
like the Queen as far as it wants along
straight lines but only forward backward
into the side easy-peasy let's get right
to practice since practice makes good
that rook right there can he move here
can he move there you can catch this
piece how long to get to that side of
the board very good next is the bishop
bishop is the other half of the Queen it
moves as far as it wants but only
diagonally when I was a kid my brother
and I used to stack a bishop on top of a
rook to be an extra queen in the
starting position the bishop sits next
to the king and queen like advisors you
start with one Bishop on a light square
and one Bishop on a dark square and you
will notice only moving on diagonals
each Bishop is stuck on the color square
that it starts on let's move this bishop
around trying to get him on to a dark
square mmm Wow that was totally
impossible luckily his buddy is here to
cover the squares he can't bishops work
well together because each covers the
squares the other one can't what time is
it now that's right
test time that bishop right there can he
move here correct
can you move there excellent what about
this other bishop over here can you go
there
and nope but he can go here candy right
excellent the night is our next study
the chess piece for a knight who looks
like a horse now really the horse is
supposed to have a writer who is brave
or not so brave but it's hard to design
that way sometimes people will tell you
it's called the knight not a horse but
it's okay with me if you want to call
the knight a horsey Knights move in a
very different way from other pieces
going to squares in one direction and
then one more move at a 90 degree angle
just like the shape of an L try to
imagine every square this night could
move to now we'll start showing them
Knights are also the only pieces that
can move over other pieces pawn in the
way enemy rook in the way no problem
people often say Knights hop because of
that special ability to hop over other
pieces
check out these night hops your BAE here
I go now I'm going to catch someone okay
no wait he knows something very special
about those hops the Knights change
square colors with every move
remember that there'll be a test later
now the pawn let's meet the pawn this is
a pawn this is also a pawn and this is a
pawn but this is a pawn not a pawn pun
is spelled P a W n the pawn is the
smallest piece on the board and the
slowest but it has a lot of potential
half of your starting team is pawns so
it's very important to understand how to
use these little guys even though
they're not very strong pawns are
unusual because they move in one way but
capture in a different way when they
move they just go forward when they
capture they go diagonally pawns can
only move four
one square at a time except for their
very first move when they can move
forward two squares or one pawns can
only capture one square diagonally in
front of them they can never move or
capture backwards because pawns move and
capture differently the pawn is the only
piece that can get blocked by your
pieces or enemy pieces if there's
another piece directly in front of a
pawn he can't move past it can't capture
that piece either of course your pawns
would never capture your pieces but not
that's another story
okay now pawns may be small ponds may be
weak I hope you enjoyed this video so
far to keep watching the rest of this
video you will need to have your parents
help you get a gold membership once
you're a gold member then you'll be able
to watch all the chess kit videos you
can also enjoy tens of thousands of
chess puzzles unlimited games and
tournaments computer training and much
much more get a gold membership and I
promise we'll do our best to unlock the
secrets of chess for you and help you
get better